هذه النافذه الانسانيه الخاصه بتداعيات
حرب اسرائيل على قطاع غزه نتابع فيها
تداعيات ومخالفات هذه الحرب على مختلف
الصعد سينضم الينا من رفح الدكتور اشرف
القدره المتحدث باسم وزاره الصحه في غزه
وسنس الضوء على ماساه القطاع الطبي في غزه
بعد مرور اكثر من 100 يوم على العدوان
الاسرائيلي نشير في البدايه الى ما اعلنته
وزاره الصحه في غزه بان عا عدد الشهداء
ارتفع الى
2927 شهيدا منذ السابع من اكتوبر الماضي
في حين بلغ عدد الجرحى
6238 مصابا منذ بدايه العدوان اشارت
الوزاره ايضا الى ان 70% من ضحايا الحرب
الاسرائيليه اطفال ونساء كما قال المكتب
الاعلامي الحكومي ان هناك 7000 مفقود تحت
الانقاض او مصيرهم مجهول بالارقام تظهر
الانتهاكات الاسرائيليه ضد القطاع الطبي
في غزه استشهاد
337 كادرا صحيه منذ بدايه العدوان في
السابع من اكتوبر الماضي اعتقال
99 من موظفي القطاع الطبي على راسهم مدير
مستشفيات شمال غزه الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
تعمد استهداف
150 مؤسسه صحيه في القطاع وخروج 30 مستشفى
و53 مركزا صحيا عن الخدمه استهداف
122 سياره اسعاف دمرتها قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي
350 ال مصاب بامراض مزمنه قد يتعرضون
لمضاعفات صحيه خطيره نتيجه عدم دخول
الادويه لقطاع غزه 10 الاف مريض
بالسرطان يتعرضون لمضاعفات نتيجه عدام
الرعايه الصحيه في اماكن النزوح بعد خروج
مستشفى الصداقه التركي عن الخدمه 000
اصابه بعدوى التهابات الكبد الوبائي
الفيروسي نتيجه الاكتضاض في اماكن النزوح
نرحب اذا بالدكتور اشرف القدره المتحدث
باسم وزاره الصحه في غزه
من رفح دكتور اشرف القدره اهلا بك في احدث
ربما ما يتعرض له القطاع الطبي والصحي في
قطاع غزه استهداف الاحتلال لمحيط مستشفى
الامل في خان يونس بالاضافه الى مستشفيات
كثيره اخرى خرجت عن الخدمه وانه كتها هذه
الحرب ما الذي بقي من القطاع الصحي في غزه
دكتور نعم بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم من
الواضح جدا من اللحظه الاولى للعدوان
الاسرا رائيلي والاحتلال الاسرائيلي يقوم
بخنق المنظومه الصحيه ويبقي المنظومه
الصحيه في حاله انهيار مستمر حيث قام
باستهداف مركز لكافه مستشفيات قطاع غزه
انهى الوجود الصحي في شمال قطاع غزه اثر
على ايضا استهداف المستشفيات في جنوب قطاع
غزه نحن نتحدث فقط عن خمسه مستشفيات بقيت
تعمل في مستشفى في جنوب القطاع وهذا العدد
فقط الذي تحمل عبا اكثر ما مما يزيد عن
19900 ال نازح في المنطقه الجنوبيه من
قطاع غزه وبالتالي الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
يريد ابقاء المنظومه الصحيه في حاله
انهيار مستمر حتى لا تستطيع الاستجابه ل
للجرحى والمرضى الذين يتوافدون بالمئات
بعد كل مجدره يرتكبه الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
في قطاع غزه هو يريد خنق هذه المنظومه
الصحيه بعدم ادخال الادويه والمستهلكات
الطبيه وفق اولويات وزاره الصحه حيث فندنا
هذه المزاعم من قبل الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
بادخال الادويه وال المسلكات الطبيه وقلنا
ان ما دخل الى قطاع غزه ويمكن الاستفاده
منه فقط هو 50 30% من حجم ما دخل الى قطاع
غزه وبالتالي ما يدخل الى القطاع من
الادويه والمسكات الطبيه لا يلامس
احتياجاته الصحيه وبالتالي تبقى الفئات
المختلفه من الجرحى والمرضى دون علاج في
قطاع غزه وهذا ايضا يتزامن مع عدم قدرتنا
على خروج الجرحى الى خارج القطاع حتى يتم
علاجهم خارج مستشفيات قطاع غزه وتبقى
الاحتلال الايه دكتور اشرف القدره للتوضيح
هنا 30% فقط مما يحتاجه القطاع الطبي في
غزه ما بقي من هذه الحاجات كيف تغطون يعني
المزيد من الجرحه يصل يوميا الى هذه
المستشفيات وامراض مزمنه سرطان وانتشار
للاوبئه كلها تحديات ربما تفرض عليكم
التعامل مع هذه الحالات كيف ت يفعلون
ذلك بالتاكيد هذه تحديات كبيره امام
المنظومه الصحيه المنهاره بفعل عدوان
الاسرائيلي نحن نحاول
ان نفاضل بين الحالات من اجل انقاذ ما
يمكن انقاذه ولكن للاسف حجم الاحتياج كبير
جدا في مستشفيات قطاع غزه وكذلك اماكن
النزوح نحن نتحدث عن الاف الجرحى لازالوا
بلا علاج في داخل مستشفيات القطاع وفي
اماكن النزوح لازال هناك اكثر من 350,000
من المرضى المزمنين بلا علاج في داخل
مراكز الاواء اضافه الى 60 ال سيده حامل
ايضا بلا رعايه صحيه 900,000 طفل بلا
رعايه صحيه وبلا ادويه في داخل اماكن
النزوح وبالتالي الاحتلال الاسرائيلي يصر
ويمعن على ابقاء المنظومه الصحيه في حاله
انهيار وليس لديها القدره على الاستجابه
لحجم ونوعيه الاصابات والمرضى الذين
يحتاجون الى الرعايه الصحيه في قطع غزه
وهذا ايضا يتزامن مع ابقاء عمليه واليه
خروج الجرحى والمرضى من قطاع غزه الى خارج
قطاع غزه تحت سندان الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
فهو يتحكم في اليه خروج الجرحى والمرضى من
قطاع غزه وبالتالي ما خرج حتى اللحظه لا
لا يصل الى 1% من حجم احتياجاتنا وهناك
اولويه لخروج ما يزيد عن 7000 جريح ومريض
كاولو اولى للخروج خارج قطاع غزه من اجل
انقاذ حياتهم ترافقنا دكتور اشرف القدره
الان هذه الصور من داخل واحد مستشفيات
قطاع غزه في اروقه الطوارئ وفي مختلف
الاقسام ايضا تظهر تلك الامكانيات القليله
التي يعمل بها الاطباء اليوم حدثنا عن هذه
الظروف وكيف ربما يستطيع هؤلاء الاطباء
اداء العمل الحساس داخل المستشفيات بهذا
او بهذه
الامكانيات نعم
المستشفيات الان خاصه في جنوب قطاع غزه
ملاه عن بكره ابيها التكدس كبير جدا في
كافه اقسام مستشفيات قطاع غزه نسبه
الانشغال في داخل هذه المستشفيات وصل الى
360% وبالتالي الجرحى يفترشون الارض
الطواقم الطبيه على محدوديتها تحاول انقاذ
ما يمكن انقاذه له لهؤلاء الحالات الطواقم
الطبيه الان تعمل بقدره 20% من حجم
احتياجات المستشفيات لان ال واقم الطبيه
باتت نازحه في اماكن مختلفه لا تستطيع
الوصول الى مستشفيات قطاع غزه وخاصه في
جنوب قطاع غزه عوضا عن شماله الذي دمره
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي ونحاول انقاذه انقاذ
ما يمكن انقاذ من الخدمات في شمال قطاع
غزه هذه الطواقم الطبيه الان تفتقر الى
الادويه والمسلك الطبيه اللازمه لانقاذ
حياه الجرحى مئات الجرحى من الحالات
الخطره
الان نحاول المفاضله بينها من اجل انقاذ
حياتها وبالتالي نقد عشرات الحالات يوميا
الدكتور اشرف القدره المتحدث باسم وزاره
الصحه في غزه من رفح شكرا جزيلا
لك ختام هذه النافذه الانسانيه نعود الى
غرفه الاخبار لمتابعه اخر
التطورات